que nous donnons surtout à la veille
d'élections la parole est à madame annie
genevard merci monsieur le président je
veux tout d'abord dire à madame la
ministre de la santé qu'elle profère des
contre-vérités sur les maladies qui
demain ne seraient plus remboursés c'est
un tissu de mensonges
monsieur le premier ministre l'étude
internationale team ce qui évalue les
performances scolaires en mathématiques
et en sciences vient de livrer ses
conclusions
les résultats des élèves français sont
affligeants tragique même disent
certains notre pays était pourtant l'un
des plus brillants il y a vingt ans
votre ministre de l'éducation ont
toujours l'explication facile ce serait
dû au nombre de postes faut le taux
d'encadrement était de 22 élèves 6 par
classe en primaire en 2009 il est de 23
en 2015
les programmes alors la baisse en maths
et en sciences et tendancielle depuis
vingt ans la formation enfin ce que nous
avons supprimé que vous avez rétabli ne
marche pas vraiment en revanche pourquoi
avez vous supprimez le plan sciences les
stages de remise à niveau et réduit
l'aide individualisée
pourquoi avoir supprimé l'évaluation
nationale qui nous rend aveugle sur le
suivi des résultats dont la lecture est
renvoyé à d'humiliantes évaluations
internationales
il faut en réalité engager un véritable
choc qualitatif en instaurant une
priorité absolue aux savoirs
fondamentaux régulièrement évalués dans
le renseignement et leurs acquisitions
la proche des sciences et des maths
passe aussi par la maîtrise du français
qui permet de comprendre les énoncés
enfin il faut des enseignants qui est
une solide culture scientifique
c'est un défi majeur qui engage la
réussite de nos élèves
et la compétitivité de notre pays cela
mérite mieux en tout cas que de vaines
polémiques et de piètres explications
monsieur le premier ministre que comptez
vous faire pour répondre à cette
situation
merci la parole est à madame najat
vallaud belkacem minutes d'allocation
nationale de l'enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche et on écoute sa réponse
déjà merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés madame
la députée jeunes va moi je veux bien
qu'on prenne les français pour des
imbéciles mais il ya des limites à tout
il ya des limites à tout donc quoi
parlons nous d'une étude team ce qui
vient de démontrer une étude qui vient
de démontrer que les petits élèves
france et de cm1 qui ont été testées en
2015 c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont commencé
leur scolarité en cp en 2011 on parmi
les plus mauvais résultats
commençant leur scolarité élémentaire en
2011 sur quoi ont-ils vécu sur des
programmes que vous avez adopté en 2008
et que nous avons changé à cette rentrée
si excusez-nous ils n'ont pas encore
produit leur effet ils viennent d'entrer
en vigueur
ce sont des élèves qui par ailleurs ont
connu un système éducatif marqué par
quoi sous votre majorité par la
suppression des postes d'enseignants et
par la suppression de la formation
initiale des enseignants
comment voulez vous que les professeurs
des écoles soit à l'aise dans
l'enseignement des matis mathématiques
s'ils n'ont pas été formés pour le faire
alors madame la députée jeunes va soyons
sérieux
vous me parlez d'évaluation je relève
que je suis la première ministre de
l'éducation nationale à avoir demandé à
ce que notre pays participent à cette
évaluation team ce parce que je veux que
les choses soient claires pour que les
français sachent que vous avez mené une
politique éducative délétère qui a
sabordé le système éducatif français
nous le relevons depuis 2012 rendez-vous
en 2019 pour évaluer le niveau des
élèves grâce à notre politique
merci madame la ministre
[Applaudissements]